[Music]
let me introduce our host for tonight
and she will introduce our speaker it's
really fun to welcome Kara play Tony to
the stage here for the third time
speaking at the interval the first time
she spoke about her book we have the
technology which I highly recommend it
includes a chapter on long now in our
10,000 year clock and some interviews of
long now folks the second time she came
and and talked about scurvy we had a
night discussing the science and history
of scurvy so as you can see we're
eclectic Kara's eclectic it really fits
and she is Kara Plutonians reporter who
actually has traveled around the world
interviewing biohackers scientists
virtual reality pioneers and in writing
her book
she's lecturer and assistant dean for
students at UC Berkeley's graduate
student Graduate School of Journalism
please give a big round of applause for
your host tonight
[Applause]
okay let's see I'm on I'm good hello
everybody thank thank you for coming out
on a school night I hope your gums are
in great health it's what I learned from
scurvy night all right so let me
introduce our tonight's guest of honor
so Esther Dyson has devoted her life to
discovering the ineffable inevitable and
promoting the impossible beginning in
the 1980s she was an important
commentator on emergency emerging
technologies with her monthly newsletter
released 1.0 which ran for 25 years and
led to her 1996 book released 2.0 a
design for living in the digital age
during the 90s she was the chairman of
the Electronic Frontier Foundation you
all can cheer as much as you yeah and at
the end of the decade she was the
founding chairman of ICANN the Internet
Corporation for Assigned Names and
numbers
more recently Esther has been a
successful investor board member and
advisor to dozens of companies with a
particular focus on health and
technology startups these include
23andme Flickr Square Evernote Meetup
prognosis and she's sold companies to
Microsoft Yahoo with a silent
exclamation point Symantec Apple Google
Facebook and uber so Esther spoke at the
long now seminar series all the way back
in 2005 when she shared the stage with
her father the physicist Freeman Dyson
and her brother the author George Dyson
so her current focus and our focus
tonight is on a 10 year nonprofit
project she started called wellville it
was launched in 2013 and so tonight
we're gonna talk about how long-term
thinking applies to healthcare so please
join me in welcoming long now board
member and founder and chairman of well
met well fellow Esther Dyson
so I thought at the beginning for people
like me who are new to well they'll will
start out with just a little bit about
how it works and what you've been up to
and then we'll take it big well we'll
talk about time and healthcare and then
we'll talk about anything you want we'll
do some Q&A at the end so first why
healthcare and why now ok so just one
other introduction mm Cristina cookus
who for many years was editor of release
1 oh and is now our 6th wellville team
member and is kind of meta because each
of the first five people have one of the
communities up here that auto drew now
so nicely for you and her community is
the wellville teen itself then there's
Brad Perkins who's one of our advisors
and has worked at the Center for Disease
Control and human the longevity ink
which is Craig Venters company and is
now has his own company called sapiens
data systems and Jeff Doland who is our
team member who works in Spartanburg
South Carolina okay if the questions get
too hard yeah we'll do an all play so
it's sometimes when I think about health
care I tend to think about either the
giant picture the national picture which
is Affordable Care Act whatever Congress
is doing to the Affordable Care Act you
know large insurers or I think about
they're really small I think about kind
of interesting things that are going on
in personalized medicine you know Health
metrics tracking kind of optimizing your
own health this is different well Phil
is different well Ville says health is
collective but it's also local and I'm
wondering if you can talk about why
you're starting in the middle okay so
basically I was a journalist I studied
economics and I did all the stuff you
heard about but in the late well sort of
in the 2000s I sold my business
and began to get more and more
interested in health care as most of the
cool stuff in tech was happening in
health care because the other stuff was
not quite as useful or significant
whatever but the more you looked at all
this you had to start asking why are we
spending so much money on repair when we
could be maintaining human bodies and
mind so much better and so the first
kind of the first lesson is it's not
healthcare as health and it's so hard
even when people are you know I write
things about health or investing in
health and it keeps ending up investing
in health care and it's not it's
investing in whatever it is and that's
sort of the whole question that actually
creates health and preventive health
care is sort of as if you were talking
about poverty reduction which people do
talk about but they should be talking
about economic development and
productivity and and you know it's it's
a creative process it's not a repair
process that creates people who are
healthy and and so forth so yeah it's
amazing I've I've learned a ton whatever
for people watching on the internet a
really fascinating vehicle is going by
it's a Gini scissor list I think anyway
robot of our future so the questions
obvious the answer is kind of we know we
should be doing all these things there's
so much evidence about the return on
investment for prevention of diabetes
for nurse Family Partnership which helps
mothers understand how to go through yep
not smoke and drink while they're
pregnant and sleep enough and talk to
their babies and understand that
postpartum depression is a phase and
just all this stuff so we just make sure
that I understand so the reason you
don't like health care as a
Costa Health is because it that implies
that it's after the fact that you're
fixing something off your opening that's
and it's medical and the whole you know
like everything else this is
aspirational I do not think we're gonna
put all the pharmaceutical companies out
of business but the problem with the
cost of health care is not the price of
health care as much as it is they need
for health care if you reduce that need
first it would be much cheaper but
second you'd have all these healthy
people running around being happy and
productive and singing all the time
wouldn't it be nice so you promote a
business on the front end that's what
you're saying yeah I mean it's when I
was first thinking about this I
interviewed a guy called Charlie silver
who created the website real age who's
running to realize you yeah actually I
remember really yeah it's basically
making sure it's its business model is
selling vitamin supplements but it's
probably done a lot of good for people's
health by making them answer questions
about do they have a pet how do they
communicate with their partner how much
do they sleep all these things and he
ended up selling it to Hearst which then
sold it to share care but it's anybody
here know who he sold his first business
to Jiffy Lube for real it was car
maintenance Wow
and yeah why don't we do four bodies in
there - what we do for our cars
you guys remember realized you would
type in all of these things I would lie
blatantly about how often I exercise and
how many vegetables I ate and then it
would say your real age is 27 you're
fantastic
you could fudge the answers but you knew
you were doing that and it would make
you want okay so let's talk a little bit
about autos beautiful drawing so these
are the five wellville cities
communities the communities health not
healthcare communities not cities five
dollars each time don't know that oh god
the real-time editing all right so tell
us a little bit about why these five was
the idea five that had lots of things in
common or their each their own sandbox
so it it originally began twenty
thirteen I talked to Peter Diamandis and
I had been on the judging panel for the
X the healthcare XPrize which ended up
not happening and the idea was take a
population of covered lives of an
insurance company apply some
intervention and do the financial model
and see who would win for a bunch of
reasons didn't happen and I asked Peter
would you mind if I just kind of lightly
said this is kind of like an X Prize for
health as opposed to care and the idea
was five communities five places
five million if we could get it in five
years
oh and five metrics very clever hmm
and I thought somebody should do this I
was gonna give a talk saying somebody
should do this well so I gave a talk
said I would do it and then I had to
figure out how I will make this very
brief but as I was exploring
brainstorming trying to figure out what
this all was there was a guy who showed
up in you know better dressed than I was
or most of my friends who asked so how
are you gonna fund this what are you
gonna measure how are you going to pick
the communities all these awkward
questions and if you didn't go away I
have lunch with him and he became our
CEO he brought in Jeff darling
so we decided well
Rick's a very orderly guy so we spent a
fair amount of time thinking about all
these questions and finally I said you
know let's let's just find some
communities so then we created this
amazing long application form you had to
be under a hundred thousand
people you had to be geographically
self-contained so the idea was whatever
happened in the community would
reverberate within the community rather
than getting dissipated out so it's not
like one of these neighborhood programs
but you never know
they don't have lunch together they go
have lunch the next neighborhood over
where they work or something and third
you need to have some kind of
multi-stakeholder coalition there needed
to be some body that was applying that
was already trying to do something with
the community's health so it wasn't
we're gonna find five communities and a
nice white lady's gonna show up and tell
you how to live it was much more we're
going to give you coaching to do what it
is that you want to do but we'll help
you do it smarter will help you find
funding but we're not going to give you
money and we're not going to charge you
not really it's it's sort of Institute I
think of it more as an executive coach
or a gym coach you know we will tell you
about the new gym equipment will advise
you which gym might be good but you're
the one who has to get up at 5:30 and
it's your body so yeah the community has
to own it and they have to they have to
go to the gym on the other hand it's
it's theirs you know and we don't give
them fish we don't teach them how to
fish we help them build their own
fishing schools so but it was more it
was almost more like Darwinian you want
something where the it's kind of like a
local Enclave whether you can West we
wanted communities that wanted us and we
wanted communities that we're already
doing something yeah so it was not a
scientific study find a random community
and do something it was more how do you
help the communities do what they wanted
to do you know we we knew especially
Rick knew a little more than
nothing and it's clear the way to make
this successful is for the community at
least have some leadership that wants to
do it okay so our goal was not to show
that it was possible for anybody but to
show that for people who wanted to do it
we could help them do it more
effectively and to show that again
everybody knows there's a real value to
doing this stuff but somehow there's not
people don't seem to believe it they
don't see there's a good example we
wanted to create models partly of
communities doing that partly what would
it look like if you actually funded
these programs and we're not we-well
vellore not funding them we're trying to
figure out how to get them funded but it
takes so it started five years but it
pretty quickly became ten years it takes
a lot of time to show that these things
are working and so many of these health
interventions last for a year or two and
if you hire grad student to do a
regression analysis you can see some
kind of impact but you can't see an
impact that is like the mayor gets
reelected that five new employers come
to town because everybody's productive
right people want to move into the
community that sort of thing this is a
slow problem
so let's son let's go to the allplay
portion of this and let's let's tell
some stories let's tell some examples so
I'm wondering if you or other people on
the team can tell me just an example of
a problem that your community decided to
tackle and maybe let's start with one
that seems to be working pretty well
some something that you think is
interesting or successful so far and
this is for you to ester whoever wants
to jump in okay we'll all start with the
YMCA in Muskegon and then maybe Jeff
will do something in Spartanburg so
one other questions so how do you figure
out what to focus on and that's both to
us and to the communities and there's
you could list 20 things that would be
valuable that would have a return on
investment that would be sort of good
and if you tried to do 20 of them
nothing would happen if you do only one
it's it's not going to have enough
complementarity you need you need a
bunch of things to support one another
it sort of like if you hire one woman
and a all-male companies she usually
disappears right
if you hire three they support one
another yeah it's this is scientifically
determined so in the same way you focus
on two or three and the way you pick
them when one that there's someone in
the community that's already doing it as
enthusiastic you pick the ones that are
going to succeed because they will bring
more people along with them a little
show that it's possible they'll make the
community feel a sense of pride they'll
train people and then they'll start
spreading so rather than take the worst
problem which in many cases is opioid
mm-hmm abuse and probably the most
insoluble problem is actually obesity
take one that somehow seems slightly
bounded and in the case of Muskegon
there's there's a bunch of different
programs the one that really excites me
is the YMCA's diabetes prevention
program and what happened there is every
YMCA in the country in theory can offer
the diabetes prevention program but you
need to have a coach trained you need to
go through some hoops courtesy of the
CDC and then you get certified in the
case of Muskegon and now I'll try and
get brief they got part of a grant from
Trinity the Health System which operates
in Muskegon in five missions Trinity is
using its own clinicians five missions
it means a geography but in the Muskegon
Mission Trinity is working with the
Muskegon YMCA to deliver the program so
that means Trinity clearly thinks we're
pretty cool the YMCA
national is noticing what Michigan is
doing they're using the money from the
CDC the scale to train people there's
still issues around getting money to
offer so one of the most important
things here is you can offer a free
diabetes prevention program you also
need to offer transportation you need to
deal with issues around child care you
need to put it in the right locations in
other words it's it's not that there's
this secret thing called the diabetes
prevention program you just do it and it
works you need to deliver it effectively
just like a hamburger restaurant you
know it's it's not like incredible IP
but there is IP around the playbook
around that the training and so forth
and the reason this one excites me in
particular is because not only do I
expect it to scale within Muskegon but
there's a way of yeah in the end the
purpose of wellville is not these five
communities the purpose of wellville is
using these five communities to spread
and scale what they're doing and so we
have aligned goals with the communities
but they're not the same we want to use
the communities and the communities we
want it for themselves so at the end of
the ten years we hope a lot of things
will spread but right now the fact that
the YMCA could help spread some of this
before the end of the ten years is also
exciting so the idea is you want to put
the the service where people are already
going it's not a medical a place where
you necessarily go for medical care
right and that they're now getting
referred so this is just local it's not
like we're Walmart partner but the two
local Walmart's are referring people
they have wellness days so they test
people for pre-diabetes and they refer
people to the Y mm-hmm so it's it's
stuff like that it's very tangible and
local and blocking and tackling but
there's still this sort of
scalable repeatable element to it okay
so if I'm going to the whites whim or
childcare or whatever it is then I can
get screened there what else would I
find at the YMCA well right now they
also have something called LIVESTRONG
for cancer survivors I mean the YMCA is
a really interesting operation and it's
again the one in Muskegon is doing a lot
more of this than most the I mean this
is not a mean thing about the Y they
will agree with it but so as so many Y's
are more focused on selling memberships
to upper-middle class people to pay for
their buildings and the one in Muskegon
for a bunch of reasons lost its building
so it's it's much more focused on
community service
it works there than you scale it other
communities like you spread it yeah okay
and but we also need to scale it within
Muskegon because they have a hundred
eighty thousand people they actually
were a slightly larger than the hundred
thousand limit and that means probably
thirty or forty thousand people with
pre-diabetes Wow really yeah it's scary
okay good
anybody else on the wellville team have
a have a favorite project favorite
project
yeah I saw I've worked in Spartanburg
South Carolina and one of the one of the
initiatives there involves some
innovative financing mechanisms so one
of the one of the other I think primary
goals of well fell is to to establish
some replicable models around how to pay
for things and in the case of
Spartanburg they have a a suite to call
it that or a collection of of nine
interventions that are going to be
available to all parents of the six
hundred 50 some-odd babies that are born
in the city limits every year and
these involve things like teaching
mothers how to be a mother and nurse
Family Partnership that as sir mentioned
before a few other initiatives and the
idea is that by the time a child reaches
the age of four five years old that
they're well prepared for kindergarten
and we know that that children who are
well prepared for kindergarten and a
performing better in third grade and
then in sixth grade and ninth grade and
presumably they're they're better
citizens and in the long run they end up
costing not only the health care system
but the education system the juvenile
justice system a lot less money so one
of the financing innovations is involves
better understanding what those savings
exactly are for a population within a
geography giving investors to pay for
the programs that will are the
initiatives that will improve the
child's outlook with these programs reap
the savings at the end of the the term
and return some something to the
investors that involves getting payers
to commit to paying back the investors
and in the case of Spartanburg the
payers are the city government the
school system and the hospital or them
by the way Esther has been using the
term health health system that's sort of
what we now call hospitals hospitals
aren't standalone buildings anymore
they're health systems so anyway the
health system in Spartanburg is one of
the three payers so I thought that
that's in the the stage of the game
where those transactions are being
structured so that payers are being a
pro
with contracts investors are being wooed
this is the phase of the of the
initiative called the transaction
structuring phase I'm sure a lot of you
know about what that is another context
and they've already gone through the
feasibility analysis and it's been
determined that that yes this could
potentially work provided that investors
and payers are willing to step up
fortunately in Spartanburg there are
enough committed there's enough capital
that's committed to improving the
outlook of the city and the payers seem
to be willing so it's really sort of a
manner now of doubting eyes and crossing
T's the outlook looks pretty good but
but this this sort of financing model is
similar to what Esther was talking about
with DPP this could be a model that
could be replicated in other communities
not the exact model but you know the
theory the concept of this paper full
performance or that's that's a name that
it often goes bust and that's that's a
something going on in this part for good
Esther how about something that hasn't
worked so uh um okay I'll do that and
then I'd really love to talk about
children and long and short term so the
what one of the mistakes I made was in
Muskegon earlier on I was talking to
somebody who was doing a flu vaccination
program and I thought that's really
great you know that's simple a quick win
and it was not that simple it's really
hard to persuade people to go get
vaccinated nobody in Muskegon was that
interested in doing it and we were
working with Walgreens and various other
people but not it had no real local
champion and though we probably got a
few hundred extra people vaccinated
and it just was fizzled so it wasn't a
quick win it was a quick loss and but it
was clear you know don't don't do
something that doesn't have a local
champion don't huh
something that it wasn't
fundamentally that very interesting yeah
it's it's great if people don't get the
flu this year but it's not really we're
gonna make them not get the flu next
year hmm and so the problem is just not
enough buying not enough buying and
frankly not enough return I mean it's
just nobody's gonna have their life
changed because they didn't have the flu
I mean somebody might have their life
changed if they had the flu and it went
really badly but it depends on which flu
right yeah yeah but still um so this
thing this thing I wanted to talk about
if she would ask me yeah so like
everyone and and perhaps why tweet
earlier than some started noticing not
so much the opioid crisis which is white
people dying but the problem of
addiction and just how widespread it was
and it clearly was getting more
widespread and there seemed to be some
relation to that and the the loss of
jobs especially sort of middle class or
slightly lower men and that's Angus
Deaton than the statistics and so forth
and it it felt kind of familiar to me it
reminded me of Russia mm-hmm we're under
the Soviets there were people just doing
useless jobs and drinking themselves to
death I asked one of my friends I said
you know you shouldn't smoke and drink
so much because you're gonna die early
and he said well life is not so
wonderful that we really care about that
you know better to drink now and be
happy
the women tended to deal with it much
better because for two reasons one they
had children and they felt they were
important in some of these lives and
they had a purpose and also they took
the money that both they and their
husbands earned and they went and stood
on line and turned the money into things
that they valued the money itself was
useless and the jobs were purposeless so
I started reading that addiction and if
anybody wants there was Gabor maté a
there was Maya salivates who wrote a
book called the unbroken brain I think
why yeah addiction is not a character
defect she said it was a learning
disorder and then I read the book that I
thought made the most sense called the
biology of desire by a guy called Mark
Lewis and if he really said that it was
learning from disorder in other words if
you fundamentally if you start your life
out with a lack of security with
unpredictable parents with basically if
your brain is damaged during the first
few years of life you become vulnerable
later on and there's there's lots of
stuff now that have adverse childhood
experiences and there's a clear
correlation between adverse early
childhood experiences and addiction
obesity dropping out of school abusing
your own children ending up in jail and
so forth and so on
so mark Lewis who is himself it was
formally addicted tells the story of
five people and towards the end he says
I don't really know what my next book is
going to be about but one way or another
it's about time and in a sense for
shortening you you lose you lose your
peripheral vision you're focused only on
this
thing you desire that you're never
satiated you you reach for it that's the
moment of desire you get it and you're
almost immediately back into the cycle
you lose a sense of time you lose your
past that was different you lose a sense
of agency I can have a future that's
different he talked about Native
Americans the ones who had lost their
sense of history are much more subject
to alcohol abuse and all those familiar
problems so I went to see him in the
Netherlands where he lives and this time
thing and this short cycle we need
dopamine we need desire to live we won't
do anything if we don't have a desire
but if your desire is only short-term
and instant it it becomes addiction
whether it's yeah I used to think this
this thing about cellphone addiction was
just like yeah yeah that's a clever
metaphor but not really but in fact
addiction is a behavior pattern it's it
can be if you're addicted to a substance
that actually has bad physical effects
like alcohol in particular or drugs that
it's worse but it's it's the behavior
pattern and that short that
foreshortened cycle of wanting something
that doesn't actually provide the relief
you're seeking much more than it is the
substance that's really at the heart of
addiction and the trick is how do you
change that short-term desire which is
addiction into long-term desire which is
purpose where there is a sense of the
future and of change and of getting some
gratification that's long-term and
permanent
so let me ask you I think there are some
people who would say the solution is
individual a person has to make good
choices they are responsible for yeah
today there are agents of their own
fortune addiction is a moral failing
personal and then there are other people
who would say no it's a structural
problem it's a collective problem right
people may not have choices all of their
choices may be bad their environment may
be constraining their choices right and
they're not making a stupid choice if
you have no job why not go out and get
drunk you'll feel better
or why not it's the only job in your
community is to deal drugs then you'll
deal drugs if it's the most lucrative
thing right yeah and that's see that's
different from addiction I mean the best
drug dealers are not addicted very smart
business people but but the point is
that your environment gives you certain
incentives choices yes mate and they can
only shoes you can only make the choices
that you have to make and so no I think
I mean you can get into long discussions
but fundamentally how many of you are AI
people yeah yeah if you need a better
training set for infant brains we've
trained our AIS we need to figure out
how to train our children's brains not
with training but yep train them that
your mother loves you and that life is
not totally secure but your parents love
you and they'll take care of you and you
need to give them a sense of security so
that they can trust in the long term in
a sense addiction is you've lost trust
and everything but this immediate
short-term source of Solace but what if
that's just not forthcoming from the
parents what if the parents are you ever
going to be able to provide that if
they're never able to provide it you
know they so we're not going to fix all
of society's ills but and you can't
waltz into any of these communities and
say we're gonna train all the parents
because you're you're really bad parents
yeah I imagine it'd have a terrible
result on the other hand one of the
things that I like about the diabetes
prevention program is it's it's not
simply here's a set of menus for
what you should eat it's it's it's very
much it's how to think about food it's
how to cook it's how to feed your body
and and look at food as a source of
energy and health but not as a source of
comfort mm-hmm it's how to feed your
family how to have dinner together and
talk to people while you're it's so it's
it's a it's kind of a lightweight Trojan
horse there's also other programs like
nurse Family Partnership that are much
more focused on at-risk young mothers
there are yet sort of couples counseling
again some people should not be married
to one another some people should
probably not be married at all and some
people have kids and you know do you
need to deal with reality but there are
ways to reach the parents and there's a
bunch of problems including many people
who have substance use problems they're
also parents so you need to deal with
different parts of it through different
programs but the ones I mentioned are
some of them that will solve some of the
problems some short term like nurse
Family Partnership dramatically reduces
things like fetal alcohol syndrome and
so forth and others of them take longer
to have an impact so well to the point
of Trojan horsing this yes and in there
so it sounds like I don't know too much
about the nurse Family Partnership but
it sounds to me like part of the idea is
that you have a backup when the
individual fails right you have somebody
who comes and says I'm gonna help you
I'm gonna be constant I'm gonna keep
helping you even though you don't know
which is right probably their own mother
is not there to help them be a good
mother for example right so you have
some kind of redundancy right I'm trying
to think of other ways that are kind of
effective to incentivize good healthcare
or good long-term thinking for
healthcare I think like education
telling me not to eat Doritos because
they're terrible for me will not work I
am well educated on the Dorito front but
I still
want to eat Doritos right so what else
can you do to get through to me well so
I mean maybe nothing we can tax the
Doritos okay - we can work with the
local food providers to sell things that
are just as delicious as Doritos I mean
and Doritos in themselves are not evil
it's yes no it's it's so people
sometimes ask us you know are all the
community members but in no mm-hmm yeah
and not all the community members were
bought into when they go into the
grocery store there's cupcakes in the
front yeah it's like you don't need to
be brought in to be manipulated and what
we're trying to do is help people
manipulate themselves for their own
long-term health and happiness rather
than being manipulated by everything
from pricing and the circumstances
around them and you know other it's it's
a very complicated complex integrated
system but it there's and there's many
different parts there's employers who
again have a vested interest in the
health of their employees yet there's
still a vending machines full of really
crappy food they have bosses who
exacerbate the mental problems of their
employees they have bad working
conditions okay so so you can penalize
the bad behavior and make it expensive
to do the bad behavior you can provide
me an alternative to my bad behavior you
can get rid of the underlying stress
that is driving me to stress eat my
genius and and to you know ignore your
children and use your cell phone while
your kid is trying to talk to you is
there a way to give a positive incentive
where the the health behavior isn't
necessarily driving it but you're doing
it for example have you seen all these
PSAs that are out there on Netflix and
Hulu every five minutes that are about
heart health and they're appealing to
parents and grandparents and they're
saying good take care of your heart
so you'll live long enough to take care
of your grandkids and the tagline is
your heart doesn't just belong to you
right and I'm sure we've all seen the
anti-smoking ones that are if you can't
stop smoking for you stop smoking for
your kid right or your breath smells bad
yes yes and then I or there's um you
know another model is doing it for the
spiritual connection or responsibility
munis or a these are all part of it and
again you can do 20 different things if
you do two or three well the others
become much easier and you know so
everywhere I go everyone tells me about
all these great programs they know that
other communities are doing and yeah
they are great and I need to be polite
on the other hand yeah I know we could
be doing all these things but I there
needs to be somebody local who actually
wants to run this program because
they're already running this other
program and what we want to do is help
them to run either to say this program
probably should be low priority or let's
run this program really effectively and
make it work before we start bringing in
three other programs and much of what we
do is helping to consolidate people
doing good things so that they work with
one another rather than compete for
resources and attention and so forth
it's just like in your own life you know
you can go to the gym you can take a
writing class I mean there's only so
much you can do and you need to do two
or three things well and that sort of
suffuses itself right you want to create
like a snowball right yeah you have
enough success that you keep on rolling
and you have enough success in the
community that the whole community right
keeps going together and then suddenly
you can model your behavior on your
neighbors mrs. Jones was in this
diabetes program and yes she just looks
happier and her kids are slightly
bouncier and wonder what she's doing
maybe I could ask
let me ask you away when it comes to
good health choices is addiction
different than other health choices
because I'm wondering what agency and
choice are like when you have a physical
dependency versus when you're just
making a more mundane choice about
exercise or eating or something like
well number one it's much more difficult
to so physical dependency is real and
you have physical withdrawal and yeah at
the end I mean we were restoration house
today which is a sort of halfway house
up in Lake County and people who are
addicted tend of all kinds of
comorbidities yeah they've partly
because they're addicted they don't take
good care of themselves so they might
have diabetes or COPD or you know it's
like rarely you're addicted for long and
you don't have something else or you
have some kind of physical problem you
take a painkiller and then you become
addicted so it's all these things happen
together number one it's it's not that
simple but when there were a lot of
soldiers who were addicted to drugs when
they were over in I think Vietnam or
Iraq and when they came back they just
stopped using because he was easy and it
was easy for them that the context was
different and so I think to some extent
the substances are over people people
don't understand that the vulnerability
to addiction is the problem not this
this is overstated don't go
you know quitting me but it's it's the
pattern of use rather than the substance
itself
some people can gamble for fun Friday
night for years and they're not addicted
to it some people I've been
that the gambling takes over their lives
so do you think that the first thing you
have to address in an addiction is
social situations social the social
environment that's driving that behavior
or the underlying depression the
underlying PTSD okay it's not whatever
it is there's no single answer it's
going to depend on the person it's going
to depend on a combination of
circumstances people need to be ready
and then the system should be ready to
take them in and the problem right now
is so in Lake County for example we
asked today this is interesting there's
probably six hundred people that are
homeless and mostly addicted there's
this house we were at that has ten beds
the woman who runs it said you know I
know a hundred people right now that if
we could take them in we could serve
them effectively and so what she was
implying the other five hundred aren't
ready and that's a combination of they
they're not ready
whatever that means it's it's their life
circumstances they don't really want to
quit for whatever reason yeah if you
could change everything around them and
it includes their circumstances it
includes psychological counseling and
includes if they have physical pain
giving them physical therapy for their
pain it includes helping them get
medically assisted treatment for the
ones who have you have the physical
substance abuse it's it's a lot of
things and the more of those things you
can combine around the person but the
person also needs to in practical terms
the person needs to walk in and be ready
for that they need to be and believe me
money is a huge part of it also you know
they need to be able to move to another
neighborhood or avoid their friends they
need to be able to get a job and many
people have yeah you can't get a job
because you can't pass the drug test or
you can't get a job because you had a
run-in with the police and you're black
and you went to jail and now you have a
record
all these things combined to make it
very difficult right so you have to have
a constellation of services that are
willing to meet people with different
needs at different phases of and their
communicate with one another so it's
real complicated yeah are you doing this
I so I live in Oakland Oakland one of
the big projects that they have right
now is starting these things called
navigation centers is this yes is the
same one I guess having it is is having
a care worker who pulls things together
for you and you know right now there's a
huge one of my favorite stories is about
this panelist in Washington DC so the
fire department actually often acts as
an ambulance and they pick people up and
they take them to the emergency room but
because of HIPAA they can't share data
with the healthcare system and so this
guy on the panel who worked for the
healthcare system he got a job as a
volunteer fireman so you could finally
get their data Wow yeah you need people
like that Wow yes so well so the idea of
the navigation centers is kind of like a
one-stop shop where somebody shows up
and they say here's the things that I
need help with I need help with
homelessness I need help with getting to
the doctor I need help with child care
and by the way if you could help me get
in touch with my daughter right or oh
and the restoration house one of the
great stories is they have it's partly
learning and it's partly they need they
they're short of space of people have
roommates and they introduced this guy
twos new roommate
and they said dad we met those guys
today Wow
well let me just ask you one more two
more questions and we'll kick it over
the audience so I'm curious if you think
this is purely a problem for the social
sciences and the behavioral sciences or
if there's a role for engineering to
play here um there's a role for
engineering I mean just to design
everything from a house to a hospital
bed to a hospital system that's friendly
to Billings that encouraged you to walk
up the stairs
and you know certainly a lot of digital
health tools I think they're useful but
primarily delivered with or through
people and ideally locally with people
you know as opposed to yeah it's again
the more we're still human we're still
wet and chemical we're not digital but I
think there's a huge role ultimately and
this is what we want influence for
policy makers who pays for this why
don't we invest in our human
infrastructure as well as our physical
infrastructure global sickening is
closer to us even though we don't
recognize it than global warming because
if we're not here to experience the
planet it doesn't matter what happens so
let me ask you just to bring it back to
the idea of time you're halfway through
the project ten-year project but ten
years we're about a third through it
ends in 2024 even though it began in 20
so it took us a while to get started
yeah that's some advanced math we figure
we pick the communities in 2014 but it
really we really got going in 2015 so
beginning of 2015 to the end of 2024
okay well even in expanded ten years
it's pretty small in terms of time right
so and health health is not the kind of
thing that lends itself necessarily to
breakthroughs and killer apps and these
kind of quick turnaround and flashy
results so I'm interested in your
thoughts on how to keep going
how to not get frustrated when it's slow
you know you it's
so I used to think gee I'm glad I'm
doing this only part-time because
otherwise I'd go crazy and now I'm more
or less doing it full-time but we were
seeing things begin to happen and
there's there's an awful lot to do but
it is slow you you have to be patient
because you're not you're getting people
to change you're not simply installing a
new software app mm-hmm but the effects
are also long-term so it's but yes you
do have to be really patient it's it's
like raising children and at the end
you're amazed how fast it was
so 2024 is a really interesting question
we're hoping they have lots of nice
scientific quantifiable evidence and and
real financial returns and and stuff
like that and also compelling stories
and it will certainly not be done I
originally committed to five years now I
committed to ten and I say that because
there's money involved and there's you
know like that's what I'm committed to
what we'll do in 2024 we don't really
know I mean with luck there will be a
few documentaries that will be amazing
and compelling and you know President
Gillibrand or somebody like that the
yeah if what we want to do is change
collective opinion about what's worth
paying for and some of what Jeff talked
about it about innovative financing and
what are what are our taxes for they
should be for investing if there were
one thing I could change about how the
US does its budget it's to call spending
on health investment and then to call
spending on health care is kind of like
it's spending you have to do but it's
really repair spending versus
investments
bending I've heard you say you're an
optimist and I'm wondering if you we
could kind of end this part of the talk
with you telling that's just a little
bit about what you're optimistic about
for help what what can we do better what
can we get right well you can do
everything we just talked about really
and and we can understand better that
it's it's worth doing this and you you
may not be able to influence what the
government does but you may be able to
influence what an employer does about
investing in their people long term you
may be a there's so many ways in which
the lucky people like you who influence
other people's opinion can start to
think differently about yeah children
versus adults let's invest in our
children let's yeah the people we talked
to today
they weren't specimens they were people
who had a bit of bad luck and we're you
know had suddenly had some good luck and
how can we make more people so you don't
need to be lucky not to be damaged by
the time you're five years old mm-hmm so
the system makes everybody a little bit
luckier yeah or makes you not need to be
lucky yeah good okay we we are also
lucky that's that's what you begin to
realize you know just good let's I think
let's take a few questions from the
audience
hi I'm Elvis jacket for me and get my
eye and I'm gonna hand you the mic I'm
gonna sneak in a quick question and the
wellville team are gonna keep the other
mic so if you guys want to be part of it
but step up on stage so we can see you
and when we do so we can all see you I'm
gonna sneak a quick question in here
Esther where does the long-term thinking
where is it best applied here obviously
you're taking a long-term approach
I don't know if every decision that's
improving health with an individual is a
product of long-term thinking maybe a
short-term thinking goal that helps them
for their lives but is it administrators
or advocates and they have the long-term
thinking where are you seeing where that
long-term thinking approach kind of is
making the most value in the communities
and you see the individuals over time
getting a better sense of long-term
thinking and start making decisions in
that way
[Music]
Christina you look ready to answer that
you get them for sitting in the front
row I just want to repeat the question
back at you are you asking where within
the communities I'd CPVC
that the long-term thinking actually
exists right now is that what the
question was where do you see the people
you're working with that they get a lot
they have a long view and that's what's
motivating them or making the program
successful or are is it just that you
have a long view and you get them
started but they may be doing it for
more short-term things they start to see
how it's a short-term benefit why I
really use it the question this way so
what's one of it really interesting
things about the work that we're doing
in all the communities is work we're
trying to build really strong
coalition's or collaborative --zz that
are multi sector across services within
the communities so not just the
healthcare systems but social service
systems the criminal justice systems
education whoever really comes to the
table and the communities and what I
find is really interesting as an
observer because as Esther mentioned
I'm not an advisor to one particular
community on Metta so what I find that's
really interesting is that is when these
these individuals who work for
institutions doing these things that are
supposed to be helping and supporting
people in these silos when they come
together and first of all learn that
they're all facing the same issues and
they're investing in some of the same
and trying to solve the same problems
often they see that they can you know
all be pulling in the same direction and
the load will be eased and all of a
sudden the sort of daily I'm gonna call
it drudgery of having to you know help
people who often are in very desperate
situations becomes you know you can all
be sensitive like instead of looking at
the next step you can sort of look up
and see the horizon and sort of really
understand where it is you're going so
that seeing that spark that goes off in
people's heads and seeing the value of
collaborating and working together I
think is one of the more inspirational
things that I've seen as an observer
since I started working with the
community I'm hoping that answers your
question
so I have a question about how you all
in the back how you all balance giving
nudges versus letting local champions
essentially have agency I think there's
a lot of kind of orders of magnitude
difference between different health
interventions so if someone comes in
with something that they want to do that
you think could be much more effective
if they just changed it do you try and
persuade both of you to let people just
do what they really are passionate about
do you want to do there
yeah I'll try but I don't think I have
an answer i I think a in a general sense
I'll speak for myself I I think I tend
to allow them that as someone who has an
idea to pursue that idea of program what
happy and there there are a couple of
things that a couple of reasons for that
one is that maybe it may be that it will
be effective
the other more important reason is that
that they're gonna learn something and
the the nature of this work is as I
think you've sort of figured out by now
it's very complex as Christina said the
there there's no one single sort of
power player in a community and if if
there is one who thinks that they have
that position there pretty quickly
disabused of that notion and and so it
we don't really know all of the the
network relationships that make a
community we know they exist we don't
really know what they are the locals
know that or they're in a much better
position than we are to to learn them
and if we allow a local agency for
instance to implement a program and it
flops that's okay they they learn
something and they they they have made
explicit some of the connections and
some of the relationships that will be
necessary in the future to implement
more successfully so I think that's I
think that's probably the general
that we take I don't think I'm speaking
just for myself there and we we also I
mean it's it's really great we we
correct one another
I mean we're learning too yeah exactly
and so no one has done this yes and we
have you know I have a tendency to think
I know the answer and it's really
helpful to have a team that just we all
correct the others excesses and it's
it's really it's I haven't ever had so
much fun I mean this is the ironic thing
I'm doing all this good work
and it's it's really great um yeah the
next person with the question is here
[Music]
Healthy Start Healthy Families first
five and they know us yeah um in each
community it's different and in Lake
County we're working with the Health and
Human Services but they're kind of
underfunded in Oregon we're working with
care Oregon which is the local you know
the the Medicaid payer plan in Muskegon
the entity that we work with is called
one in twenty one and they're a joint
venture of Public Health of miss Keegan
and believe it or not the Rotary Club so
it's it's different in each place and
you know whatever it's it's like we
don't own everything you know the stuff
that's happening in Muskegon some of it
is there without us and it's great and
we're what we're trying to do is
encourage the people we're working with
to work more effectively with everything
that's there and to yep
just become more of an umbrella they
don't need to control it they don't need
to fund it all there's this tendency to
want to be proud of what you're doing
and not really kind of ignore what the
other guys are doing but if you can
adopt them all everybody benefits so
that the government can be an important
part and they certainly fund a lot of
stuff but there is also honestly it does
not like everything we've talked about
you need to be somewhat focused and yeah
if someone in a wellville has a program
for grandparents and grandchildren I
think that's wonderful and it is and
there's also lots of things around
elder care and you know caregiving
and so forth and so on but it's it's not
our focus at the risk of maybe over
correcting Esther and and also
explaining that that by way of
explaining that that wellville is sort
of a ethereal designation for things
there's an example in Spartanburg that
speaks directly to that question
I spend enough time there that I get my
nose into things that aren't directly or
even partially under what you might
think of as the well hill umbrella that
isn't any of our communities as Esther
mentioned before there are lots of
things that are going on that we we
might not even be aware of but I spend
enough time there that I sort of catch
window of things and and the the local
hospital is part of its efforts to work
out in the community has recently
engaged a group of pastors in one of the
neighboring towns and one of the
concerns of that of that group of
pastors is the aging population and
specifically what they're concerned
about is the effect of childhood
caregivers of their aging parents and
how how to help how to help that out
they haven't figured it out but at least
they've begun to talk about it and well
you know we'll see what happens with
that story but so that that's something
that's sort of maybe not on our radar
screen necessarily but it's something
going on in the community that the
hospital is involved in we're involved
with the hospital and wherever we can
you know provide any sort of what's kind
of called technical assistance we're
happy to do so so I you know we'll learn
something about that and and it's a neat
it's being expressed and and it's of
concern to one of what you might call
our partners
sorry I think there was a hand up on the
second row was there somebody in the
second row who had a question maybe you
can pass the ball was that the question
and we're coming close to time so I
think this may be the last question I
carry baby maybe you want to but but
could everyone from the wellville team
go on on stage right now actually I
think as to the plan as you guys are
gonna stick around and so you'll be able
to talk to folks afterwards everyone can
see who they can talk to to learn more
and keep this conversation going so we
are going to what will end the stage
part but we hope you'll stick around
because these guys are gonna stick
around and we want to keep it going so
office hours was well filled yeah I
perfectly understand it's not directed
immediately though I feel it's directed
towards our collective health but given
the political situation right now so but
I'm happy to see to someone else who
really feels this it's an appropriate
but given your experience with investing
in Russia I wonder if you have an
insight that you could share with us
about the current situation um thanks
Emily so I I don't I don't want to talk
about the president specifically but the
thing the thing that seems so familiar
in Russia is from Russia yeah when I
went to Russia in 1989 and I learned so
much more about the United States in the
world then I learned about Russia from
that and I've been going there regularly
ever since I had the other security
clearance one year and I discovered I'd
been to Russia 120 times in the previous
sorry 60 times in the previous ten years
so six times a year I spent six months
living there in the Soviet Union in 2008
to 2009 because I was in a government
facility which was the cosmonaut the
Yuri Gagarin cosmonaut training center
and the thing that is so pernicious and
that I do believe they actively tried to
encourage you know what the relationship
with krump was in particular I don't
know but the that the challenge is the
skepticism and cynicism that is created
when there's not an interest in the
truth so I talked to a Russian
journalist once and I asked her so when
when you talked about the truth in
Soviet times what you know what did what
did that mean to you and she said we
really didn't care about the truth that
wasn't the point
if we would get a government handout
because all the handouts came from the
government in one form another all the
institutions were government
institutions we forgot to hand out about
the health dangers of butter we would
not care about the health dangers of
butter but we would care about why was
this particular piece of news presented
to us oh there must be a shortage of
butter and
would run out and buy as much butter as
we could find before publishing the news
when I was in Kazakhstan there was a
discussion about the said the National
telco was half owned by the government
and half owned by private interests who
happen to be related to Nazarbayev and
the news came out while I was there that
the guy running this outfit was making
one hundred thirty thousand dollars a
month there's some crazy amount and the
discussion wasn't about that amount I
mean that was yeah sure it's correct it
was what caused this particular piece of
news to be released who was behind it
and most recently I was talking to a
Russian friend about government and
politics and sort of the same question
you just asked and he said our problem
we have the no strategy we have only
tactics short term it was an
intelligible we have no strategy no
tactic no no strategy only tactics a
short-term and it's you know I don't
think it's it's that it's the short and
it comes back to yes it is short term
there's there's no long term strategy
yeah yeah there's there's not much hope
do you try to get again you try to solve
the immediate challenges you yeah you
try yeah you're surviving you know if we
can get through this day and you with
one thing that struck me when I first
went to Russia in 1989 I would write and
say I'm coming in you know in two weeks
can we have lunch on August 13th and the
person would say well call me when you
get to Moscow the week before so I
called a week before and they would say
well call me on Monday we'll set it up
for Wednesday and then
a Monday they'd say call Wednesday
morning and we and you know you couldn't
and I don't know whether they were
looking for a better offer or they were
afraid things would fall apart but it's
and it is beginning to infect us too we
are becoming I mean this is the purpose
of the long now but it's getting worse
in many ways it's it's day trading its
short-term charity yes it's give the guy
in the street two bucks instead of build
a shelter where they can recover their
dignity it's yeah cell phones and so
final I know we're getting late one of
my favorite pieces of research by
Deborah Estrin who's Judy Esther and
sister when people order online on
Wednesday for Friday night the food they
order or the videos this is back when
you ordered videos I guess they would be
more they would be healthier or more
uplifting then if you pick the same if
you went home and picked something up on
the way home mm-hmm you know we do have
long term and short term selves we're
not and this is the challenge how do you
get yourself to manipulate yourself to
make these long-term decisions and
they're you know they're all these nudge
things like buy yourself a gym
membership and then you've already paid
the money or buy yourself a gym
membership and then every time you don't
go to the gym they charge you ten
dollars or all these these clever things
that because we ourselves have these
long and short-term aspects to our
personality thank you for the question I
didn't answer before we go I wanted to
thank Esther and Jeff and Brad and
Christina with the traditional thank-you
gift of the long now this is the long
now challenge coin and now you can
redeem this for a drink at the bar oh no
keep it for the long term delay our keep
it for the long term the legend is no
one has ever redeemed it because it's
that cool so thank you very much for
your for your talking late I thank
everybody for coming out
[Music]